VERSE [by @kahliltweets]
Hello
Hello Will Ok?
Yes? No? No?  Ok...
I get to feel the excitement... Yeah...
Hello  Will? Ok?
Yes? No? No? Ok.
I get to feel the excitement. Yeah...
Ou... ou... our  return to... JavaScript...
What are you [Ou.. Ou... Ou..
Ou... Our return to... JavaScript
What are you?
Ou.. Ou.. Our return to... Javascript
Ou... Ou.. Our return to... JavaScript
What are you?
Why do you even bundle the code?
well...
Peep... Peep... People got mad
When I put it all in one file...
Why do you even bundle the code?
Well
Peep.. People got mad when I put it all in one file...
People got...
Peep.. People got mad...
JavaScript
People got... Peep... Peep... People got mad...
People got... Peep.. Peep... People got mad...
JavaScript
People got... Peep.. Peep.. People got mad
People got... Peep.. Peep... People got Mad...
JavaScript
People got... Peep.. Peep.. People got mad...
People got... Peep... Peep... People got mad...
JavaScript
People got... Peep.. Peep.. People got mad...
So, I'm gonna say things
Which are gonna be Shocking and hurtful
Which are not directed at you at all
Ok?
JavaScript is a hot mess
All they could do is add more problem... problem..
And they are busy doing that
That's only because of it's the worst API
ever developed in the history of computer science
Now the problem with
Now... Now the problem with...
As everybody knows... Right?
With JSON...
is that when you get a huge payload from your server
what is in there....
What...
What What...
is in there..
I don't know...
Let me gain something
that's not been compreciating
I didn't really...
get... that...
Preciating... Pre... Preciating...
Because, we needed more terms that no one understands
Is... Is... is Just from generic information
You know this is not scary at all...
high...
higher order functions...
you know this is not scary at all
functions within functions within functions
is such a
You know this is not scary at all
Flow of data..
inputs and outputs from the program
kind of like the concept of time
Our return to...
The skull bot...
Javascript...
Because of the little bit __ it has...
Unexpectedly
become the world's most popular functional programming language
functions are king
fun... functions are king
you wanna do everything with function
functional programming is probably the way to go
Our return to...
People got... Peep... Peep...
People got mad
JavaScript
People got.. Peep... Peep...
People got mad...
JavaScript
People got...
Peep... Peep...
People got Mad...
JavaScript
People got... Peep Peep...
People got mad...
JavaScript
People got...
Peep... Peep...
People got mad...
JavaScript
People got...
Peep peep... People got mad...
JavaScript
People got...
Peep... Peep...
People got mad...
JavaScript
People got...
Peep... Peep...
People got mad...
JavaScript
People got...
Peep... Peep...
People got mad...
JavaScript
People got...
Peep... Peep...
People got mad...
JavaScript
People got...
Peep... Peep...
People got mad...
JavaScript
People got...
Peep Peep...
People got mad...
JavaScript
Th.. The.. There is more...
There's totally more
There's always more
Everybody up inna place...
If you feel this
Put up you hand inna place
Up up... Inna space..
If you inna this
Put up you hand inna space...
Everybody up inna this Love JS
Mek me see smile inna face
JSConf hit no miss
Like when action dispatches
More than ever meets the eye to this
Doctor who enter inna T.A.R.D.I.S
Always cool, never mean a malice
Like the one wonderland Alice
More love inna this than paris
More than Rastaman love Chalice
JSConf Ways:
Code, Share
Hug up people fi days
Berlin this a the base
Nested Loops come fi tun up di bass
Everybody up inna this love JS
Mek me see smile inna face
JSConf hit nuh miss
Like when action dispatches
Dis a no C++
no Java, no Go
JavaScript run the show
Any browser any size
Run pon any device
The biggest ting already
Still we grow
Dis is no C++
No Java, No Go
JavaScript run d show
Any browser any size
Run pon any device
D biggest thing already still we grow